if you've been itching for another dose
of trials since the release of evolution
in 2012 there's not much longer to wait
for the next gen ready trials fusion
aside from being the first in the series
to hit the PlayStation platform the
PlayStation 4 is also the first to
feature stunts you can perform actual
proper tricks on your bike simply by
wiggling the right analog stick the
tricks themselves are based on freestyle
motocross and are hooked into the
physics system so when you're hanging
off the back of your bike performing a
superman the extra weight means you've
got to quickly adjust your angle so you
don't spin out the tricks look awesome
in action and there are specific levels
designed just for them featuring big
jumps and ramps as well as fmx specific
challenges speaking of challenges there
are over 120 in the game including some
unique ones that have you flying a
rocket powered bike through the air and
playing tennis with the disgruntled
penguin the meat of the game still
involved guiding your motocross bike
over ever more challenging obstacles
though and it's enormously fun as ever
to play levels especially bright and
colorful this time around gone are the
overly brown areas of old replaced
instead with sharp shiny surfaces and
heaps of bright colors the levels are
even zanier too with all sorts of
explosions and moving platforms that try
and send you crashing headfirst into a
wall should two wheels not be enough for
you fusion also features a quad bike
there are some levels specifically
designed for the increased speeds and
slightly more forgiving handling of the
quad but you can take it out on any
track including the multiplayer ones
which makes for some wonderfully
topsy-turvy races trials fusion is
shaping up to be just as compulsive and
experienced as its predecessors and it
looks mighty fine to boot it's also
coming to retail with retail versions
coming bundled with a season pass that
gives you access to future DLC
expansions and content look out for it
on pc playstation 4 xbox one and xbox
360 soon
you